this morning on the dish a superstar of
seasoning Leora left circars is known
for spicing up the dishes of both
restaurant kitchens and home cooks our
own co-anchor Michelle Miller met up
with him in the fall when his new book
mastering spice came out I wake up in
the morning I put some in my tea in my
coffee in my the self-proclaimed king of
spices you put spices in your tea and
coffee they do can't help creating
flavors beyond the ordinary it's
exciting I put it in water even
throughout the day in a bottle of water
put some chef Lior loves the car says
it's just in his nature it smells so
good right now what is it about spice
spices are one of the most important
things in the culinary world but also in
the world because it's it's a rare
ingredient that touches everybody and to
me it was a happy place because it
connected me all the time to food that
connection has led to a very successful
business his blends which can include up
to 23 Earth's and spices are sought
after by some of the world's most famous
chefs including Erik repair and Daniel
Boulud it was a good boy very passionate
very serious very committed and at the
same time leo is an artist an artist
whose medium ranges between nature
there's really no limits on what you can
do with these blends and nurture I like
this one yeah a different peppers fruity
too floral the hints of the citrus are
just boom boom tiny too pungent mmm
blends curated at times to the taste of
each customer we spent quite a bit of
time with each person that comes here to
ask him some simple questions you know
what do you cook what do you like what
you don't like we have them smell and
taste a bunch of spices it's interesting
because often they'll say oh I don't
care much for this and they'll end up
buying it really well because they have
a pre notion of something that they
don't like let's say celery seeds I
usually ask them
who did something wrong to your celery
in the past what happened to you in
celery Leo loves the cars was born in
Israel which is where he started cooking
professionally but he spiced up his life
after a move to France while training
with michelin-starred chef Olivier
Rowland Jay he wasn't still is very
influential in my life and my my career
cooking and spices he was very smart in
in the idea of explaining to me that the
spices that he was using were just a
tool the same way that he had a great
knife or a cutting board and he said I
want you to develop your own personality
when it comes to taste scent and flavor
by tasting these things and I'll be here
to help you along the journey that
journey ultimately took him to New York
City to work for chef balloon but after
six years and with balloons blessing he
realized he could pursue a food career
without being tied to a kitchen what was
it about the kitchen you didn't like I
never liked the service aspect of it and
that slowly convinced me that perhaps I
need to keep on developing food flavors
and scent but outside of that
environment you gave him an incredible
piece of advice which was hey the
cooking isn't all there is for the
restaurant business
clearly leo will always be a chef I
think he saw this opportunity to be able
to remain a chef and very involved with
the commitment of creating foods and
making food starting over
blending in his basement for the first
few years then in 2011 he finally opened
his own storefront
lebot in New York City what he came to
realize just like in the world of food
there is always more to master in the
spice world how much have you explored
in the realm of spice can you say a
hundred percent no way I just came back
from India after 12 years in a business
one of the most important moments was
for me to stand in the equivalent of 50
football fields where they trade chilies
on a daily basis it took me back to
basics and I knew a lot
ready so when you ask me how much do I
know I don't know if I can quantify it
but I don't know that I'm even halfway
to where I want to be and that's amazing
is this the new frontier in the world of
culinary cuisine I think for Leo what
was important is to first source unique
spice cumin is cumin but maybe the cumin
from a certain region of a certain
country is better and then from that is
to be able to create simple and unique
blends who will be almost a trademark to
him these blends but we will connect
with the chef mine circars still does
business with his old boss he's now just
one of his best customers
chef Baloo uses those blends in
everything from his chicken tagine and
when we say spicy it's not hot spicy to
cocktail this cocktail has been made
with gin which is a collaboration with
Leo and the gin has been made with some
Indonesian berries and some mint from
Israel Oh Cheers cheers to you oh my
it's perfect where do you go from here
the unbelievably exciting thing for me
in the last 12 years is that there's no
day that's the same I don't know who's
gonna call and who I'm gonna meet chefs
and pastry chefs and chocolate makers
and beer brewers and distillers and
champagne makers it's so exciting and
the opportunities are endless little
piece of good news for this industry
right now Lior told us this week all of
his employees are working and that the
store is open for pickup
he says online sales went up about 40%
this week because of all the people who
are now cooking at home fantastic to
hear